moving on our main story tonight
concerns justice is the thing best
served by steve harvey
this court
is going to award you
a vip moment
you
and your girls
finally give you an additional five
thousand dollars
from me and my court
and you take young girls to vegas
and party like it's 1999.
that's my verdict
and that's how i see it
incredible right just top to bottom
great from awarding a woman a vip moment
as if that phrase means anything to the
entire gallery clapping for the
plaintiff including the defendants by
the way
demanding she organize a vacation with
all of her friends every google
calendar's nightmare and that is saying
nothing of the mvp of that clip steve
harvey's little golden gavel which he's
making a full five course meal out off
honestly i wish i had one of those
except hold on i actually do
ordering the course hong kong big man
tiny hammer alert poppety bobby klump
i'm a gavel guy now get used to it
sadly though not all courts are as
infallible as steve harvey's as we've
discussed many times on this show trials
can go awry for a number of reasons from
prosecutorial misconduct to underfunded
network public defenders to floor jury
selection to how we let judges to
problems with mandatory minimums all the
way to flimsy jizz analysis luckily
though as pop culture has repeatedly
taught us there is a remedy for wrongful
convictions built right into the system
the fight is on the pill
it doesn't offer i'll get the conviction
overturned on appeal of course i'll be
appealing i'll appeal this all the way
to the supreme court you will appeal
this don't say anything it will appeal
okay hold on because let's just
acknowledge julianna margolie's there
because she is capital a acting in that
moment doing absolutely everything with
absolutely nothing julianna margulies is
doing more in this three second clip
than the rock has done in his entire
movie career you heard me i've said what
i said
the rock's been officially clamped
but the idea the idea that you can
simply fight a wrongful conviction and
get exonerated runs deep but the truth
is it is far more difficult than you
might expect even if there's compelling
evidence that you are innocent take
lamar johnson who was convicted in 1995
of murder but between his conviction and
his sentencing one of the real killers
wrote him a letter that you would think
would have changed everything for him
the letter opens by saying it's pretty
much messed up johnson was convicted
when he didn't do anything then explains
who did it and what happened believe it
or not even with the letter this is
still a fight and the justice system is
trying to figure out how to free an
innocent man i never expected that this
case would go
the way that it would that it did that i
would end up
charged with and much less convicted for
it and would have to be here for the
last 20 some years trying to prove that
i didn't do it okay so there's clearly a
lot to unpack there from the fact that
it didn't say it was messed up it said
it was [ __ ] up to the fact that it
opened with what's up dude which is a
weird way to greet a person who's in
prison for something that you did how do
you expect johnson to respond to that oh
not much you
but it is not just that let up both the
real killers have now signed multiple
affidavits swearing that they committed
the crime and that johnson was not
involved and if life for a game of
monopoly you'd assume that's it that's
an automatic get out of jail free card
unfortunately though life is not a game
of monopoly for one thing no one these
days can afford to buy property and top
hats are only worn by amy sherman
palladino and the babadook so as of now
johnson is still in prison and it's very
much up in the air whether he'll get out
and if you're wondering how the [ __ ]
that can be the case
that is what our story tonight is about
it concerns all the reasons why if
you're wrongfully convicted even if
there is compelling evidence of your
innocence it's really hard to be
exonerated and let's start with the fact
that the constitution guarantees the
writ of habeas corpus which is to
protect against unlawful imprisonment
basically you have a right to challenge
your incarceration and you can do that
in both state and federal court but as
this defense attorney explains there's a
major limitation on that right
it's not just enough to be innocent i
mean that doesn't get you anywhere you
have to have something else to be able
to get back in court on yeah that's true
in general innocence itself is not an
appealable issue a fact already so
shocking it might prompt you to go the
full margulies she was in the background
of that scene giving it that kind of
commitment
now what you can appeal on is any
shocking new evidence that wasn't
available during your original trial or
a claim that your constitutional rights
were violated during it but that's
already a long shot especially because
while you have a right to an attorney at
your original trial you are not
guaranteed one after your conviction
most states do provide one in death
penalty cases but even then there is no
guarantee that they'd be competent and
attorneys can be incompetent take gedis
anderson he represented a man named
edward lee elmore in a murder case and
he lost it elmore was sentenced to death
and while on death row appealed his
conviction he petitioned for a different
lawyer but was told that he had to stick
with anderson who had only spent eight
days preparing for his original trial
and who can only be described as the
most tennessee williams of characters
in retrospect perhaps i should have
asked for more time
i never had proclaimed to be
you know the best lawyer that ever
graced the courtroom
yeah well that's not great is it the
only thing worse than being a bad lawyer
is being a bad lawyer with low
self-esteem
in the words of rupaul if you can't
defend yourself how in the hell are you
going to defend somebody else
and the thing is you do need an
exceptionally good attorney for an
appeal post-conviction law is incredibly
difficult to understand even for a
seasoned attorney and you want to get it
right because any technical error can
result in your appeal being dismissed so
many wrongful conviction cases are won
or lost on technicalities even ones that
are pretty compelling take ricky kidd a
man wrongfully convicted of murder in
1997 despite the fact no physical
evidence linked him to the murders the
case against him was littered with
police incompetence and prosecutorial
misconduct and his own lawyer failed to
chase down exonerating evidence such as
the fact that around the time of the
murder took place kid was in a sheriff's
office applying for a gun permit which
is a pretty [ __ ] solid alibi
kids best grounds to appeal whether he
had ineffective counsel at his first
trial but unfortunately when his new
lawyers filed that appeal they failed to
include that argument so the state
fought to keep him locked up which is
both outrageous and something that the
assistant state ag was comically
unwilling to discuss you don't have any
concern that a police commissioner and
former prosecutor say he's innocent
i mean according to your name is here
right in the court document
and you're not even arguing that he's
guilty just technicalities that he
missed his chance to properly appeal
you don't seem concerned about this do
you even think he's guilty
answer i mean you're spending taxpayer
money to fight this case you're keeping
them locked up in prison
is that the best use of taxpayer money
y'all have a good day sir
wow honestly i'm a bit conflicted there
because obviously that man is a
heartless monster smirking like a wack
statue of paul giamatti when a man's
life is at stake but i do also respect
his ice cold attempt at ignoring small
talk in an elevator
elevators are flying coffins that demand
total silence from each of their
pallbearers we have to reach agreement
on this
and while it's not important quick shout
out to the guy waving at the camera in
the background there hey buddy hey bet
you had no idea at the time that your
wave was underscoring a grotesque
failure of our entire judicial system
but it was it was bye
but that actually brings us to a key
point here which is when the whole
criminal justice system is geared toward
getting a conviction it has very little
interest in seeing its work undone so
for instance i mentioned earlier that
one of the few ways to get a
post-conviction appeal is to argue that
you have new evidence to introduce but
you still have to be able to show that
it would have changed the outcome at
your trial and prosecutors will fight
that notion hard when one of the west
memphis three tried to get a new trial
based on new evidence including dna an
assistant ag appeared before the state
supreme court to try and talk them out
of considering it citing the harm that
could do
what harm is there to allowing him to
present all evidence well the harm is in
the finality of a criminal judgment that
is
not demonstrated to have any
constitutional or procedural defect and
just to try it again i mean you're
suggesting it sounds to me just as
previous though every 15 or 17 years or
so we we really ought to try cases again
to reestablish guilt so the harm is
in is to the criminal justice system's
interest in finality hold on the harm is
to the finality but if the final
decision could be wrong you should want
to make sure that you get it right
there's a reason that la la land didn't
just keep the oscar after faye dunaway
and warren beatty skin smiled their way
through that mistake
but while thankfully those judges were
skeptical many defer to prosecutors that
was the case with edward lee elmo
remember the guy whose initial lawyer
was insecure foghorn leghorn the key
evidence against him were hairs at a
murder scene the police claimed were of
african-american descent but there were
no photos of those hairs at the scene
which was already suspicious and the
state later found a box of evidence
previously claimed to be missing by
police that contained caucasian hair
recovered from the victim's body during
her autopsy but when the judge was
presented with this pretty important new
information he simply wasn't interested
this is a completely different case than
what the jury heard if this is not
enough to grant somebody a new trial
then when is post-conviction relief ever
appropriate unexpectedly rather than
adjourn and read the filings before
ruling judge kinerd issued his decision
on the spot
all motions are denied
oh it gets even worse because that judge
went on to say that obviously the
evidence should have been disclosed to
council but as far as impacting the
original verdict i don't think it would
happen in closing he said good luck to
everybody i'm out of here which is a
terrible way to wrap up a court
proceeding the best of course being this
that's my verdict
and that's how i see it absolutely
unimpeachable
but the thing is a quick ruling like
that is not remotely unusual many times
appeals judges will just sign the state
prosecutor's documents without even
changing the heading one study looked at
post-conviction appeals in the largest
county in texas and found judges adopted
the prosecutor's findings verbatim in 96
of their rulings and if at this point it
seems like our whole system is set up to
preserve its process even at the cost of
human life well during one death row
appeal before the missouri supreme court
for this man joe amrine one assistant ag
basically admitted as much
you're suggesting if we don't find
there's
a constitutional violation then even if
we find that mr amaran is actually
innocent he should be executed you're
supreme court
holy [ __ ]
you know you're on the wrong side of an
argument when you're asked should
innocent people be executed you say
that's correct your honor that's the
kind of question that only has one right
answer like is the queen dead the
obvious answer to that being yes
absolutely she's been dead since 2007
and it's a good thing it's a good thing
it's a good thing ordering the courts
ordering the court
and so far everything we've discussed
has been at the state level but what
about if you appeal up to the federal
court well in some cases they do step in
to overturn egregious convictions but as
this defense attorney will tell you
that's very much the exception
we all understand that the role of an
appeals court is to get it right
and if it gets it wrong
then it will be fixed down the road in
the system that's the belief that we all
have in the system
if some court gets it wrong another
court is going to come along and set it
right federal courts can only grant
relief if a state court was unreasonably
wrong was so wrong that no other judge
no other fair-minded judge could
possibly agree
with the state court
that's an incredibly high bar yeah it
really is because no fair-minded judge
could possibly agree is a hugely high
bar to clear reasonable people disagree
all the time on issues like which way
the toilet paper roll should go or how a
tortoise would wear clothes is it over
the shell or under the shell there's a
vibrant discussion to be had here there
will be dissenting voices
the truth is federal court's hands are
tied pretty tightly by something called
edpa it stands for the anti-terrorism
and effective death penalty act it was
passed in the 1990s in the wake of the
oklahoma city bombing and at the time
the justification for it was we cannot
let terrorists like timothy mcveigh or
any prisoners on death row appeal their
cases endlessly here is the argument
back then in a nutshell
what about the fact that many have now
uh sit on death row for years and years
and years with access to the libraries
and computers and everything they could
possibly need so that they continue to
drag out this process there's got to be
an end to it okay that's actually an
even worse argument than it seems
because remember this was 1995. the only
thing computers were good for back then
were minesweeper and still images of cal
ripken junior i'm guessing that in 1995
if you typed post-conviction habeas
corpus appeal into lycos.com your hard
drive would spark into a full-blown
house fire
so prisoners sometimes having access to
computers clearly wasn't the real
problem here and although edmund sounds
like it only applied to terrorist and
death row inmates it applies to everyone
and in addition to that high bar that
gutted federal view of state convictions
it also imposed a strict one-year
deadline to file a federal appeal once
your conviction is finalized which i
know might sound like a lot of time to
you but it really isn't a federal appeal
is a massive undertaking often involving
doing new research speaking to experts
witnesses previous attorneys and
investigators one year can not be enough
as proven by the fact that post edpa the
deadline had been missed at least 80
times in death row cases 80 times death
row prisoners went to the trouble of
filing an appeal only to be told sorry
too late it doesn't count and even when
filings do come in on time that high bar
means they're less likely to be
successful to the point that while
before edpa 40 of death row defendants
succeeded in getting their verdict or
sentence overturned in federal court a
decade after it that rate had dropped to
just 10 percent and i will say this
there was one senator who saw all of
these problems with edpa pretty clearly
at the time and he warned against what
might happen
this just doesn't make sense in my view
mr president as a practical matter or as
a matter of principle
we should not in our haste to hurry up
executions lose sight of our commitment
to constitutional values we should not
endorse proposals that increase the
chance that where execution is imminent
that an innocent person be executed we
should not i believe
sacrifice certainty in the name of speed
or fairness in the name of vengeance
yeah pretty good right pretty good i
know it is weird to see joe biden
actually on the right side of a criminal
justice issue in the 90s it's like
watching home movies and seeing your
bitterly divorced parents passionately
frenching each other it's just hard to
imagine a world where that ever happened
so enjoy that feeling for just a moment
are you enjoying it i really hope you
are
because now i have to tell you that
biden actually voted for the bill in the
end and you don't get to be surprised by
that the guy is who he is
and all of that brings us to today where
many wrongfully convicted people are
still locked up with a racially
disproportionate impact innocent black
people are about seven times more likely
to be convicted of murder than innocent
white people and at the same time those
who actually committed the crimes are
still at large as the philly d.a points
out
justice means that you try to do things
that are proportional and you try to do
things that are accurate if you're
trying to do things that are accurate
that means you do not want the guilty
person who got away to continue to get
away and you also don't want the
innocent person to stay in jail because
that ain't right i mean
duh
yeah he's right [ __ ] duh
you've probably already been screaming
that in your tv for the last 15 minutes
along with talk a bit slower and this
guy's a furry right and that's my
business but i will say this the clues
are all there
but again he is right we know
prosecutors are fallible even when the
stakes are incredibly high and if you
want to see this whole maddening system
in one story consider the case of
melissa lucio she went through the most
horrific thing imaginable the death of
her two-year-old daughter after a fall
down a flight of stairs but the police
suspected foul play and over the course
of a marathon interrogation the night of
her daughter's death lasting until three
in the morning they pushed her to
confess to murder
basically what they were doing is they
were trying to
make me admit that i was
the one responsible for her fault
and i kept telling him that i hadn't
that i hadn't hurt my daughter and
they were very vulgar
very
very rough very
resistant this is your chance to set it
straight because right now it looks like
capital mortar right now it looks like
you're a cold-blooded killer
now are you a cold-blooded killer or
were you a frustrated mother who just
took it out on
we knew somebody did it
we're trying to find out who did it
it happens
okay we all make mistakes
we all make mistakes we are getting
upset we already know what happened
we already know what happened
look i know that's upsetting to watch
but it's really important to see just
how aggressive and manipulative the
system can be in someone's most
vulnerable moments that lead to things
like false confessions because after all
of that she told those officers what
they wanted to hear that she had in the
past spanked her daughter the state then
argued to the jury that that counted as
a murder confession and she was
convicted in a trial where not only did
the prosecution keep the jury from
hearing psychologist testimony that
could have spoken to her mental state at
the time but her own defense attorney
decided not to call her other children
to the stand who testified that they
never witnessed any physical abuse from
her and yet
when she tried to appeal her conviction
to state court the judge was apparently
in such a hurry he initially tried to
rule for the prosecution before the
defense had even filed their response
and when it got to once it got to
federal court a split ruling denied her
appeal but even the judges who ruled
against her admitted there was expert
testimony that if jurors had only heard
it could have impacted the verdict going
to acknowledge we are although working
within the constraints of edpa
melissa lucio is now scheduled to be
executed on april 27th
next month
and to hear her prosecutor tell it
there's only one person to blame for
that
she has nobody blame for herself
she has nobody believe it herself
you know people say well she shouldn't
be there she shouldn't be there well you
know she put herself there
whose fault is
it whose fault is it that she's there
if it's not hers
i mean i can take a crack at that answer
if you want because it starts with not
hers and while it isn't a complete list
it includes the cops who badgered her
the texans who voted for a governor who
seems unwilling to intervene ted cruz
i'm assuming somehow
the 91 senators who voted for edward in
1996 hammurabi for codifying capital
punishment in ancient babylon and you
for prosecuting based on a confession
that wasn't even a confession you
[ __ ] [ __ ] so
with a system so fundamentally [ __ ]
what do we do well immediately we can
get rid of edpa and we should do that as
soon as possible especially if the will
could actually be there considering how
against it biden once briefly was in
addition we should continue to address
all of the many factors that lead to
wrongful convictions in the first place
and when they do happen we need to make
sure that we've elected prosecutors who
will undertake conviction integrity
reviews and governors who use their
pardon power to undo the state's
mistakes we need to make this a priority
because right now we have a system where
people can be wrongly convicted with bad
defense attorneys and left a fight in a
convoluted appeal system with little to
no help at which point it really feels
like our system is essentially guilty
until proven rich or lucky and that has
to change because we cannot keep letting
the most vulnerable be casualties of a
system that cares more about quick and
final decisions than actually correct
ones that is my verdict and that's how i
see it clump clump [ __ ]
[Applause]
you